actors we're we're surfers you know
we're just
catching the wave
but
the filmmakers and the writers and the
producers you've got to build the wave
so the actors can catch it and surf
when did you stop being an actor jeremy
and go from in front of the camera
to behind the camera as a writer
director
sure so i you know i had continued my
acting career
all throughout my teen years up through
my early 20s and i think the last film i
did as an actor
i was probably
25 so over 10 years ago um
and and before that though
you know i'd still sort of
been acting a few times you know for for
friends for projects where you know
for instance actually the last two films
i did as an actor
were
really personal connections people that
i knew
who were gonna be making a feature film
and they were like listen we need
one last actor for this one last part
and we think you can do it and i'd go in
and these were again these were friends
and i would read for them
and um you know they'd be like great
you're it and you know we'd go off and
we'd make the film
so those
that's actually my last two experiences
as an actor
um
and then so that was through my
early twenties
and i think even during that i'd been
sort of experimenting with
my friends and we had been sort of like
still wasn't really getting into it you
know i
i i was still kind of an actor
but like little by little we had started
writing
um we had started filming like
small webisodes
um we had really been
you know just just sort of practicing i
feel like people sort of like at least
for me
you know i had kind of grown up on sets
and so i'd seen people doing it
but i hadn't done it myself and so these
were my first sort of like little
experiments at like trying to do that
myself shooting it myself and editing it
myself and
writing it myself and sometimes acting
in it myself and sometimes my friends
would be acting in it
um
and and so i think it was around that
time so really my early twenties were
when i stopped
being an actor full-time
and started doing my filmmaking and
producing full-time
um
and i started out small you know with
web series
webisodes sketches and at that time
there was like
you know a lot of stuff you could do
like funny or die or these places where
you could you know submit your comedy
sketches or your webisode sketches and
and you know hopefully you could kind of
find an audience or build an audience
that way
and um that's kind of what we started
doing and
then as i sort of progressed and i think
a lot of people do that do it this way
where they you know you kind of get a
little bit better and then you make the
next one and it's just a little bit
better and then the next one's better
until finally you're at a place
and this is this is where i was and
where i was with my my friends at that
time where
you know we were like okay
all of this
stuff that we've done has been fun but i
think now
it's like there's a there's always i
feel like a
like a a a switch or like you're you're
ready to like
go to the next level you know there's
that evolution of like this was
everything i was doing and now i'm going
to
one-up it
and
at that time my friends and i started to
make a web series
and one of my friends one of my
collaborators still my one of my
collaborators to this day which is
why i'm talking about relationships too
is that you know the people that you
meet and your friends and the people
that you work with
um
are
you know who you know and it's about
knowing people right
um
but one of my friends had this great
idea for a kind of a comedic
web series
and we could serialize it and break it
into many different parts
and his ideas were about these
you know mobsters from the east coast
who have to come out to the west coast
and it's this sort of fish out of water
comedy story and we were like great
that's a great idea let's go with that
and that became
sort of the first
real
web series we did called mobsters
and i i know it's still available out
there on funny or die or i'm sure i'm
sure people if they're interested can
look it up
um but it was a lot of fun in
and i i want to say that was the first
time we really decided to
you know step it up
or really up our game and go to that
next level and really take it seriously
um
and it really worked out well we had an
amazing experience with mobsters
and uh we still like that idea to this
day you know they're your ideas are
always they're always there in the back
of your head even if you're not actively
working on something now i i feel like
nothing ever really goes away it's
always there
um
so we we've always kind of got it in the
wings but that was a great experience a
great web series
we learned a lot we worked with a lot of
excellent actors along the way um if
people want to look it up they i mean we
had excellent guest stars in some of
these episodes we went to
some excellent film festivals with some
of these webisodes
and i think that was
really um
eye opening to all of us
especially me to be like wow like
we could actually make some really
excellent stuff if we just
you know put our mind to it
did you ever regret stepping away from
acting what was part of the allure of
making your own stuff not having to go
on auditions it's an interesting
question
stepping away from acting
you know
for me
i kind of
explained that like when i was younger
and
when i was getting into acting
for me it was
the actors were the people that i could
see
you know when you're a kid you're
watching film or you're watching
television and you see the actors so i
immediately thought well i've got to be
an actor if i want to be in in movies
and it was this really interesting thing
happened where
you know when you're on set you know for
instance using dante's peak as an
example
you're on set
and
it was like a light bulb went off
i mean it really was like
oh my gosh
like i get it it's
that there are the actors and i'm one of
those actors in this situation
but then there's a director
and then there's camera operators and
there's costumers and there's grips and
there's
all of these people making these movies
that i love and that you know the
television shows that i love
and it was like oh
whoa
i get it
like i'm i'm starting to
realize like
you don't just have to be an actor if
you love film or television there are
many
ways to do this
um
so for me
you know i think i being an actor was
sort of
almost a means to an end it sort of got
me involved in what i wanted to do
but it wasn't necessarily the only thing
i wanted to do
um
and you know i continued like that for
years
you know being an actor and so all
throughout my teen years again up into
my early 20s i'd done
you know
numerous television shows guest spots i
was you know
series regular on a show that ran for
seasons i had done independent films
starred in independent films but that
whole time
you know you're watching and you're
learning and you're observing
and you're seeing like all this
different stuff happen
and all these different jobs that people
are doing
and
and and for me stepping away from acting
was
you know i i loved acting and still to
this day i love actors and i love what
actors do and it's very easy for me
because of my background directing and
producing and writing now it's very easy
for me to relate to actors because i
know what they're going through
um
but but i kind of see it as all just
i i always think of myself as just a
filmmaker
you know and that can be
producing and that can be writing and
that can be directing that can even be
acting you know i don't think
um specifically there's
one category or i have to fit you know
only one thing so you know stepping away
from acting was um
[Music]
it just felt like a natural progression
because what i wanted to do was actually
more storytelling um focused
and uh but still to this day i love
acting i love actors who knows maybe one
day
you know maybe i'll go back to it i
don't know
why is being an actor easier than being
a filmmaker
i don't
gosh i don't know if
i don't know being an actor is easier
than being a filmmaker um
you know actors are really
the talent that actors have is so
special it's really an amazing thing
because for actors and and i think i can
say this i think i've got enough
you know sort of acting cred behind me
that
you know and i've worked with some
amazing actors i really have um
but the talent that they have is so
special it's a it's it's there's this
incredible
focus
and presence um
for an actor that they are just so
in it you know they have to be just so
so right right there you know what i
mean
their mind can't be wandering and it
can't be thinking about
something else and i think
for
for filmmakers
i think it's it's sort of a different
mind where your mind does have to sort
of be able to
focus on multiple things at the same
time whereas i think
acting you really have to be focused on
one thing
um so i i wouldn't say it's
any
easier to do one or the other i just
think that it's it's a completely
different sort of um
[Music]
discipline and mindset and focus that
each one needs
um but but also you know
it can really depend you know now that
because i have been both an actor and i
have worked as a filmmaker
and i gotta say they're both tricky i
mean they're both difficult you know
like being an actor is is its own thing
you really have to get used to
auditioning
you have to like auditioning
you have to really feel comfortable
doing it
um as a filmmaker you have to get used
to
pitching you have to get used to
you know
uh
there's a lot of like personal meeting
people you have to get used to calling
people
on the phone and like really you know
being
sort of uh
tenacious with that too um
but i i also see like moving ahead as a
filmmaker or getting a project off the
ground as a filmmaker is also extremely
difficult um i know this because i've
tried it and i've had so many projects
that are almost there and
and don't quite um
you know for whatever reason all the you
know
come to fruition the way i'd i would
like them to
and that same thing can happen to an
actor um where you can you know almo you
know
you can you can get the callback the
third callback the fourth callback and
you're so close and that doesn't really
happen
so i just think they're completely
different
disciplines i think but i think both of
them are
have have their own challenges
do you ever breathe a sigh of relief and
say
oh now i don't have to wait to be picked
on i can i can be the picker
you know i
i do breathe a sigh of relief sometimes
that i don't have to wait
to be cast in something that i can
just go out and make it you know myself
and and i will say that that
that freedom is something that is so
amazing about being
a filmmaker is that you can just
go out and do it you know you write it
you put the crew together you produce it
you find the locations you cast the
actors
um
you can you know you can work with the
editor or you can edit it yourself but
yes absolutely having the freedom to
just go out and create
is wonderful and i think but i think on
the same same token you're seeing a lot
of actors now getting more into that
themselves i think a lot of actors are
you know sort of taking the reins for
themselves and
you know shooting scenes for themselves
or you know doing self-taping for
themselves or even like i've seen a lot
of like sketches and stuff on like
youtube or things like that where it's
just an actor with their phone
and they're kind of shooting
both both parts of the scene or they're
shooting you know over the shoulders and
they're shooting you know they're making
it look like they're two different
people so i think
i think
i think actors are starting to
get into that indie filmmaker spirit
but
but yeah it is
it's an amazing freedom to be able to
just go out and start making stuff and
it's funny because i
the last short film that my wife and i
made was called the faceless man
and um
i remember speaking to
our actors and
one of our actors just saying you know
actors we're we're surfers you know
we're just
catching the wave
but
the filmmakers and the writers and the
producers you've got to build the wave
so the actors can catch it and surf so i
think um
you know
they one hand needs the other you know
one doesn't exist without the other but
it is it's uh it is nice to
to just go out and do what you want